is there intelligent life in the
universe will we
one day be able to time travel and which
one of these two scenarios is more
likely
and what if aliens were actually
future versions of humans today
on what if discussed
[Music]
welcome to what if disgust i'm peter
schmeichen and i'm richard garner
so pete aliens do you believe in them
do i believe in them i mean please i
mean that's a long conversation it's a
complex conversations we're going to
find out today but let me start with you
do you believe we are alone in the
universe
does you and me here yes just you and i
well of course there's two guys crew
behind the camera people here as well
but uh yes we're on a bit of an island
but i guess what i mean
are human beings on the big blue marble
here
unique uh i'm going to say yes
i think yes we are unique in that we are
probably and this
is very uh hubristic i'm sure
that we are the sole intelligent species
in at least our galaxy
i don't know what's happening in the
other galaxies nobody does obviously
it's smart to say well there's this many
planets that are in
goldilocks zones of suns about the size
of this and
earth's with this and with gravity and
water and blah blah there's got to be
you know they say thousands of planets
similar to ours
doesn't mean that there's intelligent
life on them there could be
amoeba on them so you're open to life
i'm open to life for sure
i think if there is something as
intelligent as us
it would have found us well maybe not as
intelligent as us
a little smarter than us it would have
found us if it's not as smart as us
it wouldn't have found us why would
fermi paradox
well there you go yeah share me paradox
like that but the to your point the idea
that we would have sort of bumped into
each other at some point whether they're
looking for us
whether they would have found us whether
we would have seen evidence of them
over the course of x amount of time i
would personally argue that
our time that we've had that level of
advanced technology that we could know
those things
is a blip in human history
so we still get caught up in the idea
that we kind of
got things figured out and i think it's
very early in the game
and you know if we've been around you
know the planet's been around for four
billion years
this version of human beings supposed to
be a couple hundred thousand i guess
hundred thousand whatever it is so is it
possible that
you know in a couple of thousand years
we would have more information and
ability and telescopes whatever to be
able to figure this out better
but the math is compelling to me i do
believe that exo you know the more
exoplanets we find
it seems to be like a yearly thing now
right it's like every second week you're
hearing about oh they found an exoplanet
at your point that
you know whether it's uh or or even when
we grew up
water on mars was like forget about no
chance
bam we find evidence of water on mars
right there was always little green men
yeah and that was the interesting
starting point it's a good sort of segue
to what we're going to be discussing
today because
that idea that kind of got you know
imprinted on us to your point from
probably science fiction when we were
kids and
was this idea that there was a very
specific kind of you know
look look to a short sort of hairless
big eyes
green or gray large brain large brain
take us to your lead like that type of
stuff so a it was easily dismissed and
marginalized but b
it kind of created this idea that that's
what we would be looking for or
expecting
because it also coincided with a lot of
you know ufo uh um
accounts of of whether it be seeing or
abduction whatever
but what i hadn't considered before
although it was kind of pitched to me by
my brother-in-law a sci-fi book idea
back in the day
that was similar to the
theory that we're going to be discussing
today with the auth well literally the
man who wrote the book on the subject
about the idea that in fact not to say
there's no alien life
but that these visitations these these
grays these little agreement or whatever
we've discussed over the time
aren't actually from off planet or alien
they're in fact
us from the future time traveling back
now that how how does that land with you
more or less compelling more compelling
and more
possible i would think because if we if
we are us
in the future then of course we're going
to be smart enough to be able to come
back i don't
anticipate that any alien uh race is
coming to visit us
for any reason and why would they make
themselves so scarce and so
so mystical and invisible yeah to us but
yeah
us in the future and this could be the
future being
40 million years yes not talking about
200 years this is not some sort of
you know back to the future three
business this is like
this is like us we've already moved off
the planet onto some
some sort of uh o'neill cylinder and
we've come up with the possibility of
coming back and visiting
the old people on earth i like this and
uh and for various reasons which we'll
probably get into
a little later but uh i think that's
more plausible that it's us rather than
it's
some other species that evolved at the
exact same time as us
over you know all we know is four and a
half billion years of
living in the universe for all we know
the universe has been around for
infinitum yeah at infinite so they're
who knows yes it's so a little mindful
well you know you might know
our guest today our guest well shall i
introduce him yes perfect timing
today's guest literally wrote the book
on the subject
dr mike masters is a professor of
anthropology
at montana tech university dr masters
received his phd from
the ohio state university and has
participated in
archaeological digs all over the world
his passion for the study of human
evolution
combined with a lifelong interest in
ufos led him to write
identified flying objects in which he
postulates that
aliens are not in fact alien at all
but are in fact humans from the future
time
traveling back to better understand
their past
by better understanding us
dr masters thanks for joining us thanks
so much for having me on guys
pleasure to be here so before we start
going down the rabbit holes i guess what
prompts or inspires let's say a phd
level anthropologist
to really take on two of the biggest
rabbit holes out there
aliens and time travel
well it actually started when i was only
about eight years old
um some friends were over at our house
and i overheard my father telling
a story about a ufo he saw he was a
veterinarian
in amish country in a pretty rural part
of northeast ohio
and um i just remember it peaking my
interest and
it wasn't long after that that he got
the book communion by whitley strieber
and i remember very vividly looking up
and seeing that book on the living room
shelf
and i had this image pop in my mind for
those that aren't familiar the book has
sort of the quintessential
gray alien on the cover and i remember
having this mental image of
an early hominin or chimpanzee-like form
a modern human in the middle and then
this
quintessential alien form on the right
side and i had sort of a what-if moment
i
thought well what if they're just us
from the future
uh coming back through time to study
their own evolutionary past so
wow it was something that kind of stuck
with me throughout my life and
um i've always kind of pursued that
question and
eventually decided to take a little
farther and spend
a good amount of time investigating it
and writing a book about it
now dr masters you stress that this is a
multi-disciplinary
scientific study and not just
speculation tell us about the process
and the time that went into it
yeah well once i did finally decide to
start putting
words to page it was about actually i
remember
specifically october 2012
uh i was coming up on tenure i was
getting close to
promotion the full professor um and i
thought you know what what better time
to do it
and so i hired a couple research
assistants and
sort of explained the premise to them
and we
mostly focused on the the the different
disciplines multi-disciplinary
the ones we focused on specifically were
physics
astronomy astrobiology and in my field
of anthropology
and biological anthropology um
foremost and yeah over the course of the
previous seven years we
just kind of worked to build a case
around this looking at the
extraterrestrial hypothesis
as an explanation for these craft and
the beans that purportedly pilot them
and just to kind of see what the most
parsimonious explanation was what made
the most sense in the context of what
people described seeing
and it seems to fit very neatly into
this time travel model
well of those disciplines you mentioned
anthropology being your
area of focus and expertise
help us understand through your
understanding of human evolution
why this then is not a really massive
leap going forward that you know how we
might evolve as human beings
a thousand years from now millions of
years from now and how that
fits into sort of really creating the
foundation for this theory
yeah i mean i started off as a physics
and
uh astronomy major as an undergraduate
and then switched to anthropology
late my sophomore year and uh decided to
look more at the human evolution side of
things and it's always fascinated me and
i'm really glad i
uh did that i've gotten the opportunity
to work in diggs in south africa 3.5
million year hominin
site australopithecus africana
specifically
a neanderthal site dating back to 150
000 years ago in southern france
well led digs all around the united
states here where i've lived
um so the main crux of the argument i
guess looks at these long-term
evolutionary training
trends throughout human evolution so um
initially
we were quadrupedal just like all other
hominoids just like pretty much every
other
mammal we're tetrapods we have four
limbs we have penidactyly we have five
digits on each limb
but then something unique happened
between six and eight million years ago
and we stood up we became bipedal and
that's
actually the characteristic that defines
the hominin clade
is our bipedalism and as that happened
what needed to happen is that we had to
rotate our heads down
so we could see where we're going and as
that took place there's a number of
craniofacial changes that occurred
uh most notably there was a flexing of
the basic cranium
so the part of our skull where the brain
sits there's the anterior
the middle and then the posterior and as
that flexed
in order for us to see and for all of
these changes that take place
in association with bipedalism it
created more space
within the skull for a brain to grow and
we often times talk about the slinky
hypothesis and brought a little slinky
along the show
but first of all i love i'm loving the
props by the way thank you
oh yes especially slinkys i mean how can
you go wrong with that
so if we imagine the back end of the
slinky is the foramen magnum
the part of our skull where the rest of
the body connects through the the spinal
cord
and as that rotated down so our heads
could sit more on top of our skulls
and our face rotated down and backwards
you can see that there's all this space
at the top
where it created more room for our
enlarged brain
so that took place in association with
the reduced face
um the traits that now define our
specific
species homo sapiens sapiens is what's
called a
globular for neurocranium we have a big
round head
it's always sort of increased the
frontal lobe and the parietal lobes have
expanded mediolaterally meaning left to
right
but this globular nero cranium that we
have today
is a trait that defines us as modern
humans going back about 200 000 years
we also have a chin a mental eminence
which is unique
to our species our hominin ancestors
don't have that
so long story short if we look at these
trends that have continued not just in
our cranial facial anatomy but our
post-cranial anatomy too
and if we project those into the future
we're very likely to have these same
traits
that are so commonly described in these
instances of close encounters
specifically the big round heads the
large
wraparound eyes oval shaped eyes reduced
faces even beyond our own
little tiny pointy chin smaller ears
more childlike traits i talked about the
atomy and paedomorphosis in the book a
lot so
just looking at these dominant trends in
human evolution if they continue into
the future
we are likely to look very much like
these alien beings
mayonnaise no metamorphosis zoe you said
yes
pressure yeah i mean we don't really
know what that is
they're not common in terms so nyotny is
this
uh process that characterizes human
evolution as well and all it is
is the retention of juveniles traits
into adulthood so
we we retain more infantile
juvenile childlike characteristics even
as adults and we can already see this
throughout human evolution if we look at
a modern human
and we compare them into an infant
chimpanzee and an adult chimpanzee
we're much more like the infant
chimpanzee because they have those
juvenile
traits and i actually argue in the book
if you look at
children now especially young children
even fetuses
they have these very alien-like
characteristics big round heads big eyes
small faces
so if this same trend continues into the
future this paedomorphosis
um it could help explain why they look
so
infantile they're oftentimes described
as being childlike
or uh sometimes even fetal i came across
a report recently that described them as
being overgrown fetuses i think was the
words they used
yeah um okay so we've explored the
future
us part of the equation but uh what
about time travel
if if we're going to give you the
benefit of the doubt that
you know we've cracked that nut sometime
in the future
um how are we do how are we doing it how
are we coming back
yeah it's a great question and obviously
a very important
part of this model is what about time
travel is it even possible
um there was a really interesting study
by earman at all
that came out in 2009 called do the laws
of physics forbid the operation of time
machines and i looked at
all of the different theories both pro
and con
a lot of people like stephen hawking was
very anti
time travel so they looked at all of
these different theories for how it
might work
the actual physics behind it but then
also looking at philosophy and history
philosophers have been debating this
question of
time travel for centuries and what is
time they they
really originated this question um and
what they found is that there's nothing
in the laws of physics
or in any of these other disciplines
that forbid
the operation of a time machine and
specifically backward time travel so
that's a good argument in favor of the
fact that it could exist but
the actual how to get to your question
specifically
ever since einstein published his theory
of general relativity
back in 1915 there's been a number of
solutions to his field equations that
were published in association with them
that demonstrate how we could create
closed time-like curves
and essentially what that means is that
we if we think of
a light cone this is usually how we
conceptualize the future past and our
present
even though the present arguably doesn't
exist if you turn on a beam of light
it shines out a flashlight say it shines
out this light
everything that can take place has to be
within the boundaries
of the cone that forms as it radiates
outward simply because nothing can go
faster than the speed of light
so in order to travel into the past we
have to somehow orient those light cones
downward toward the past and a number of
solutions to these field equations
starting
uh with uh lens
and thurine in 1918 we have van stockham
in the 1930s
uh the godelmetric this rotating
infinite
infinitely massive universe um and then
eventually with frank tipler in 1974 i
think it was
published a paper showing how we can
create this frame dragging effect this
warpage of space-time that reorients
those light cones toward the past
which allows an individual to travel
locally still into the future they're
still going forward
but globally they're going back into the
past and and since then
there's been a number of other studies
that have shown the same thing that if
you have a
large enough mass or a big enough energy
and it's rotating at a very high rate of
speed
that you're able to create these closed
timeline curves and
many descriptions of these ufos are
describing that
that same thing to kind of tie this
together
a large disc shaped object
spinning at a very high rate of speed
emitting a tremendous amount of energy
there's this
overwhelming static electricity in the
air electromagnetism is always described
in association with them so in the
context of
everything that's been shown about how
we do this in the laws of physics
seems to fit nicely with how these craft
actually appear to be
so you've piqued my interest uh and now
then we we sort of move on to again
let's sort of grant you
you've you've passed the next stage of
of uh verification of validation and now
we get to alien abduction
where that's been described in many
cases you know we kind of hear about the
probing or the
anal probing or whatever you know but i
mean you it's sometimes made into a joke
but then in in some cases of people have
described some pretty horrible
events whether it be to farm animals
back in the day with cows and whatever
but basically if you were to zoom out
and look at it you'd say
you could say objectively well there's
something going on there's some
learnings
you know that there are some things
trying to be derived from it it's not
just
random so you've described in the book
that
yes well this could be scientific
research from
future us coming back here to understand
something
about what's going on here that could
help in the future whatever that might
be so let me put you on the spot
again you're an anthropologist let's say
we figure out the time travel as we said
uh earlier and now you're being asked to
go back into the past
to be part of a team to go and do some
research first of all are abductions on
the table and
and secondly would you would you be up
for it
oh absolutely i mean even just to have
the opportunity to meet
future humans in our time and to observe
their
morphology their craniofacial form their
technology their
their way of communicating which by all
accounts seems to be telepathy
which is fascinating to me at least at
some point in the distant future we
may acquire that ability whether it be a
technological implant or just some
aspect of the
brain itself there's no way i could know
that
um but yeah i would absolutely go along
i think it would be
tremendously fascinating to go to any
point in the future and especially
because
so many of these reports there is um a
really
interesting study by the dr edgar
mitchell foundation
former astronaut who was really
interested in this question sixth man to
walk on the moon
yeah yeah and and they found that the
overwhelming majority
of contact experience were positive they
really enjoyed interacting with these
beings they described
this this really impactful sense of
empathy
and love and always talking about
avoiding violence and war
so to be able to live in that world or
even to visit
it for a short period of time i think
would not only be
really mind opening but it would also be
a really great experience just to feel
that more evolved sense of human society
and
love and compassion um but your question
about
what we would do or why we would do it
yeah absolutely abductions are
completely
on the table um i i think
that the abduction phenomenon is largely
anthropologists from the future
doing exactly what i would do if i had
access to this technology now i'd pick
them up
i would take hair samples saliva samples
skin samples
vehicle samples as you mentioned the
anal probe thing so much from poop i
mean it sounds weird to say
but that's how we know that we consumed
about 7 000 calories per day
as neanderthals and mostly meat by the
way is that we found their turds
and we could break those down and look
at the molecular composition and realize
that this was their diet so
if you want to learn not just about
people's diet but so many other things
about them
you can definitely do that through fecal
matter
um so beyond that i mean they picked
them up they
uh and i'd like to preface this by
saying too that this is a more tenuous
part
of the argument we don't have proof of
this happening
recently the navy and the pentagon
confirmed the tic tac
ufos that were observed in 2004 and then
another one more recently
so we have confirmation of these craft
now which i think is great
but we still don't have anything that we
can really put our finger on and say yes
that's an abduction and that's happening
so with that said if we do take these
people seriously and if we do look at
all of these different reports the fact
that they're doing exactly
what we as anthropologists would do if
we had access to this technology
really indicates to me that they are in
fact us and they're
largely here to gather information it
seems weird to me though because
uh we document everything seemingly in
this
uh day and age so if it is in fact
we coming back to investigate us
what exactly are we trying to learn
because isn't it all laid out in the
table
yeah i mean that's a great point if it
would almost seem
and based on the physical traits most
commonly described and especially those
grey alien forms
that this is a very distant point in our
future we're talking tens of thousands
of years and
even with our best technology to archive
paintings and the data that we have now
electronically
look how fast our iphones change and our
computers change
even if you were to go back and try to
find information from 100 years ago
especially with wars we're constantly
blowing up archives and
and destroying monuments and bits of
information
um it's possible that they won't survive
and
and it may also help explain why we
don't just see
regular old humans that often why would
we come back to a time where we already
have that information it would make more
sense
to come back to a time when we don't
have it anymore we've lost that
it's not available to us and especially
the biological data
so does this particular
hypothesis which is the us
the future us coming back time travel to
again learn more about
previous generations of human beings
uh on the evolutionary track
to probably help whatever it is we're
trying to solve in the future
does that though take off the table the
idea that there's
also possibly other intelligent
species in the universe who also are
traveling throughout the universe and
potentially even coming here as well
no not at all i i don't see these as
mutually exclusive at all
and i i also acknowledge the psycho
cultural hypothesis in the book that
it's really once we started to become
space-faring beings ourselves
that we get more ufo reports and we
would have a tendency to
anthropomorphize those as well and
interject
our own appearance onto them by thinking
well if we're going to space there must
be all of these other civilizations that
are also doing it
and that those things need to be
considered um
but the fact that life arose here on
earth so soon after it could
uh in the context of the 4.5 billion
year history
of the earth 3.7 billion years we start
to get prokaryotes
and we're very simple cell single
cellular organisms for a long time
reproducing
just by mitosis dividing and it took a
very long time to get to where we are
so that could definitely happen on
another planet however it's very
unlikely
that on that planet wherever it is in
the universe that they would have a
similar gravity
to us it's already difficult for us to
walk by italy we
suffer from what's known as the perils
of being bipedal a paper by the
former director of the natural history
museum in cleveland published this back
in the 70s
bruce latimer was his name specifically
that we
suffer from things like herniated discs
bad knees
bad necks varicose veins hernias
hemorrhoids all of these things are
a negative result of being bipedal so if
we had
a slightly larger planet that was more
than 9.8 meters per second
squared gravity we're not likely to be
bipedal at all and what we've found
from a number of studies carried out by
the arecibo
observatory in costa rica that only
about 2.2 percent
of all the planets that have been
discovered as part of the kepler mission
are actually the same size as or smaller
than earth so if we have more gravity
we're not likely to be bipedal like we
are it's very hard for us here
we're one of the only mammals that is a
habitually bipedal
if they have a different chemical
composition a different distance from
their sun different atmosphere
they're not likely to have the same dna
coating system that we have
there's so many reasons why they
wouldn't look anything like us
so i definitely don't discount that
there's life on other planets i just
don't think that
it necessarily helps explain the ufo
phenomenon
and the contact the experiences that are
so ubiquitously recorded
so we are special pete to some degree it
sounds like
we're special especially yes well i'd
like to think so anyways
look this is this is wildly fascinating
we could go on all day about this
uh but we really appreciate you not uh
not only
sort of taking us on a journey but also
doing it with
you know the benefit of your background
expertise and pedigree
as as you know as an anthropologist
and taking a real serious look at
something that i think is obviously
something that at the very least
fascinates a lot of people and at the
very most is something that people are
going to consider more and more as we go
forward so thanks for that
where can people find more about your
work
uh well i have a website for the book
and i have a new book coming out later
this year
uh the website's just a shortened
version of the title identified flying
objects so
o id fly i'd fly object.com and there's
links to
um all the different formats of the book
audiobook ebook
and obviously paperback and it's more
information about speaking events which
have obviously been somewhat curved
on account of the virgin soil pandemic
we're all dealing with but
um there's just keeping people up to
date largely through the website
and i strongly recommend it's not just
again a fascinating read as
as a sci-fi uh you know book might be in
this particular case it's kind of like
you're reading i don't want to say a
textbook because that might sound dry
to people but it's certainly you're
being taken with the benefit of
this sort of the parallel scientific
explanation or theorization
for everything that's being tabled which
you can appreciate kind of like star
trek back in the day right like when
they would
at least introduce the new ideas and go
and explore
and but you'd be like oh that's
interesting because they explained the
science behind it theoretically i could
see that existing one day and
as we know many of those things do exist
some of it is
speaking of the prime directive in in
in that show i mean trying to avoid
interjecting yourself or
influencing them too much that's the
same thing we see with this phenomenon
and you would expect that
of a time travel model but not
necessarily if another being schlepped
across the universe to get here
we would expect them to at least get out
and say hello or kill us all and take
our resources or something but
the fact that that doesn't happen i
think lends more credence to this time
travel model as well
very good point and great point to end
on thanks a lot dr masters for joining
us and we'll catch up with you down the
line appreciate it
all right thanks guys thank you so pete
where are you now after talking to dr
mike masters for a while
are you leaning towards the possibility
that we
are in fact being visited by future
versions of us
well i believe it even more now i
thought
we would be talking to someone who's out
there
a little bit out there yeah i didn't
know much about dr mike masters before
today and it seems that he's a very
intelligent man
and has done a lot of research into this
and believes it with all its
with all his heart so i think he's got a
point and it's
very possible well it's interesting the
approach from an anthropologist
right i mean you've heard also probably
a thousand books written on different
subjects of ufology with various ranges
within the spectrum of credible to crazy
or whatever it might be but what i had
never come across
was the idea of an anthropologist's
perspective on this
so we as humans or
present day humans are often guilty of
believing somehow whether stated or not
that evolution ended here
right like we're done like it was always
all those like
homo erectus cro-magnon finished with us
every day i mean why would you think why
would you go through life you know going
to the pharmacy thinking that
yeah yeah that there's 2 million 3
million 4 million years or
some people might say no because we
might not be around
that's a what if that might be well
that's a question for another what if
but that's a good point is that we're
living in a nihilist society where we're
about
we assume we're all going to die that
global warming is going to knock us off
we have to leave the planet
this world may be over so why would we
even imagine that there's
another paul the sci-fi is dystopian
almost every future version or vision
of humanity is post-nuclear war or post
zombie apocalypse or post whatever
yeah and people don't necessarily spend
a lot of time thinking a about a
long-term future
for the species these days especially
but b they don't postulate the fact that
well wait a sec
if homo abilius and neanderthal looked
like this
hundred thousand two hundred whatever at
a three-point mill whatever
then what would we evolve to look like
in a million or two million years and dr
mike masters makes a very good point
that
everything is trending unfortunately i
can't remember the name off the top my
head about the uh
the the immature thing the fetus yeah
yeah yeah
like the idea that we actually are
taking on features of
we're becoming we becoming fetal yeah
the aliens are all they all look like
giant fetuses giant babies and or babies
all look like
well obviously aliens look like giant
giant babies egg
or chicken there and i mean i was happy
because i was i've been telling people
for years that
i am i am devolving and i'm getting more
immature i
certainly are but in terms of traits
though like i mean it's very interesting
because
without that connection the you know the
little green men you talked about or the
gray that we've seen in movies it was
just some sort of
abstract thing that oh sure whatever it
was somebody's idea as to what an
off-planet
being might look like but if you do
start to and again i mentioned my
brother-in-law before
he had he had pitched this idea that
global warming
which obviously isn't that far-fetched
even though he was pitching this 20
years ago
ultimately forced us underground as a
species the sun got hot whatever it was
the the the ozone layer was too whatever
and we could no longer live on the
surface of the earth
and human human society moved
underground and
lived underground for thousands and
millions of years and his
theory was that well obviously if you
were living underground you'd get
shorter
you would have you know the your eyes
would be bigger because it'd be less
light all of the same things as
kind of dr masters was talking about
will be part of our natural evolution
but again from an anthropologist that
now sort of
it makes the whole idea a lot more
plausible
wow yeah it's i mean it's a lot to i
mean prime directives
we're talking about you know a whole
bunch of different things but in the end
again you talked off the top the idea of
somebody coming here from
you know some other galaxy and whatever
and just
watching us for a while visiting
occasionally doesn't sound speaking
it sounds less plausible than this which
at least there's stake here if
we meaning the future us are them
are them coming back here
we're coming back for a reason yeah it
would be there it'd be more than just
curiosity
there would have to be something we
think we can learn that's going to help
us
in the future i think so the perils
of being bipedal yes was my favorite
line if i had a nickel for every time
i said that if you liked this episode
and want to spend more time with dr mike
masters well
stick around click on the link in the
description below to check out
our extended audio version we carry on
the conversation with dr mike masters
we'll see you next time on another what
if disgust